welcome back to big mood
tiff that was really cute and sexy thank
you because her tits are out
i'm trying really hard because because
we have cat here
welcome cat and you might know her from
a couple podcasts like fighter and the
kid
and king and sting exactly but and
she was also on jk news but now we have
her here yeah
and we're actually going to be talking
about cats
only fans yeah we're gonna go in
and that's why i decided to like try to
you know let the girls out a little bit
i've noticed that no one has been able
to convince you
to even think about going on only fans
more than this young lady right here
exactly here's the thing
people only i feel like people scare you
about only fans and doing it and
especially when you're kind of like a
woman in the industry it's almost like
looked down upon like
you're supposed to post sexy photos but
only if it's on instagram and only if
it's for free
whereas like the moment you put it on
only fans you're monetizing off of it
for some reason some people have issues
with that
and i'm telling you bite the [ __ ]
bullet and do it bite the
people and monetize off of whatever you
want i don't know
i can see like the whole so i made it i
posted
okay i posted a joke um on my instagram
like several months ago where i was like
i
i would love to show my ass because i
love my body but i can't stand the
thought of making men happy for
free yeah so i'm like i get that i get
that well you can charge jess
men love your sexuality so long as you
don't monetize off of it right
yeah that's the thing like how dare you
monetize off of me sexualizing me
exactly how dare you i i i i've been
saying this for years like
people are always like oh yeah porn
stars are gross only fans is gross blah
blah blah is gross
you can't hate on something that you
actively consume
yeah that's [ __ ] up that's like going
to the mcdonald's getting food like [ __ ]
you
i understand why they do it though
because it comes from a place of shame
like they're ashamed that they consume
it they're
they're shaming themselves so in order
to avoid that confrontation with
themselves they have to avoid the people
that are doing it right
absolutely i mean avoid uh shame you
have to shame the people that are doing
it makes them feel better about
themselves somehow mm-hmm yeah exactly
that's stupid because they're the ones
who actively look for it they're the
ones who spend the most money on it
exactly yeah i think i don't remember
which country it was but it's a country
that really actively shames
women's sexuality it really oppresses
them but uh
statistics show i think it was on
pornhub that that country consumes the
most porn
probably i mean yeah it makes sense but
even in the us it's the bible belt
oh yeah that makes sense yeah the more
you restrict something the more you want
it
yeah exactly whenever you're on a diet
and you're just like oh i shouldn't be
eating that because i want to die you
want it even more
that's what they say about christian
girls man see it's restricted
is anyone a christian girl in here can
anyone confirm i was raised buddhist
excellent i was raised catholic oh my
family was always just
never spoke about religion ever yeah so
i guess agnostic or atheist i don't know
no one in my family was ever like
strongly against religion or
not so it's just kind of a thing just it
wasn't even a factor in my family
but so now you do only fans but you
don't actually do
like pornhub style only fans where
you're like
spreading your [ __ ] lips and [ __ ] right
no oh my god i'd have
multiple houses right now if i did
here's the name um my boyfriend actually
used to do porn with his ex-girlfriend
that's because she
is a very well-known very successful
porn star and he started doing porn with
her when only fans first started popping
off
and so because i'm with him people
assume that i'm doing porn
and i don't so some people will
subscribe and they're like oh i thought
you were getting [ __ ] i'm like no
it's like my feet oh so they're all
disappointed yeah it's like people
disappointed because
they'll see like feet at first and then
they're like oh and then they see a
picture of me and like a wet t-shirt
with my nipples popping out they're like
oh okay i'm back in i see so you don't
ever show any nudity whatsoever but
you're still
no i extremely successful i uh classify
it more as
lewd photos rather than nude photos so
it's like
anything that you see on instagram from
i would say like the generic like
instagram model i would i would do too i
would do like
something that won't get pulled off yeah
like i could post everything that i do
on instagram right now and none of it
would get pulled
so you're not sweating you're spreading
toes yes spreading time oh my god
i'm doing it in my shoes right now you
can't see don't spread the lips
but yep why did i try to spread my lips
on inside my jeans i was like wait can
you
and i was like wait can i wait i can
push it but it doesn't spread
imagine if you can control your lips
spreading that'd be sick how
intimidating would it be
[ __ ] a guy and you're possibly just
go yeah or like if you don't want to
you're like
nope you know that'd be sick have you
ever gotten a cramp on you one of your
[ __ ] lips because i have no
why yes it's [ __ ]
painful what were you doing i don't
remember you know what you were doing no
it really wasn't
gonna let you [ __ ] slide it sounds
like you were having a great time
first of all i wish i was so far behind
your head
no she's cramped up like a charlie horse
no i have done some crazy stuff and
never cramped up
i don't remember what i was doing i
think i was like squatting picking
something up or
doing something or maybe i was sitting
squatting on that dick
maybe i think it was because i was
wearing some really tight jeans
and you know like that that [ __ ] like
yeah what
this knob right there where like the
gene
like crosses there's like in the
crosshairs it's like really
kill shots all so that [ __ ] was digging
in
i think if i remember correctly it was
digging in on one of the side like one
of my lips and it actually cramped it up
and i was like oh my god how do i
stretch this
[ __ ] it really hurts yeah there's no no
i was just rubbing the lip because it
was hurting but it was not pleasurable
at all casey walks in he's like
oh you're like no [ __ ] off no that's not
it it hurts
like i'm not touching myself out of
pleasure yeah that was painful
i imagine that's like getting do you
guys get nutsack cramps ever
george says nurses now i i feel like
probably they sit on their own that's by
accident sometimes oh yeah
it's so nice to hear george's laughter
in the background again i know george is
back
i was just making fun of him like oh you
have a baby now you think you're so
[ __ ] cool [ __ ] that baby you've known
us longer
we should have priority over that stupid
kid
[Laughter]
so that's cool i mean like there's
websites out there
archiving our feet that we accidentally
show in our pictures
for free for free it's called wikifeet
yeah and someone has sent it to me
yeah you know i'm not on there you're
not i'm not sexualized by our audience
the way
i know no no no i'm not challenging
anyone but i'm just saying i'm not
sexualized by our audience the way
everyone else is it's crazy
i'm like kind of happy about that
because i don't have like
a [ __ ] ton of creep like tiff has the
most
weird deep fakes like the crate like i
don't know what it is about him yeah
like they are obsessed i've even gotten
hit up by a few
uh publications wanting to interview me
about the deal really stuff
yeah that's insane yeah cause like i'm a
mom
and you know i'm a public figure and
like how does that affect me and all
that
but i i so i did one interview but it
didn't get published and then the other
one i was like
i don't kind of want my name to just be
attached to this
it's because you're the most like one of
the more conservative ones amongst all
of us like you julia that's really what
it is they want like the
seemingly like shy meek ones because
they're like i don't want to sexualize
the [ __ ] out of it i think
she's the most feminine i honestly i i
personally believe tiff is the most
feminine out of all the women in our
group
oh really i do not have one a shred of
bro in you at all there's no bro in you
none yeah what what about the extreme
sports side of me
no it's still so feminine the way you do
it it's just like
it's so beautiful like everything you do
like it's graceful when you're flying
off the plane your lashes are
all pretty [ __ ] you probably have like a
trail of paint going down
pink vaginal juice flower i'm like oh my
god
i think that's called discharge yeah i
should get that i just don't like the
words
[Laughter]
no but i mean i i guess like i guess
that's probably why but then
i don't know like i try showing my my
like not so meek
side more more comfortable confident
side and
and yeah people still explain i don't
think it's meekness
i think it's just that because even when
you're confident just everything about
you is like the ultimate
feminine energy it's also what people
project on to you
yeah that's really what it is because
you can be like a b
and c but all they're going to see is
what they want
they're just going to project whatever
it is that they saw and i feel like a
lot of the times they'll project
what they like assumed you to be
at your like initial period so it's
almost like they then disregard all the
growth that you've had when you're like
oh i'll let my personality out a little
more it's like if you start something
especially on
online in my opinion i was always like
very shy and didn't want to say anything
didn't want to do anything
that would be too like like
seemed like i was trying to get
attention right i didn't want to speak
in the shows i was working for at
all i was like ah private instagram i
don't want anyone i'll block anyone who
even dm's me
i was just nervous about that and now
like that image still kind of stays with
me
today even though i'm like super raunchy
and i don't give a [ __ ] about what i say
that's awesome
oh you've changed i'm like you didn't
know me [ __ ] yeah exactly
how were you able to break out of that
and like your initial like not wanting
to share anything about yourself to now
having an
an only fans like that's i think i just
stopped caring
that's really what it is because i feel
like it was a waste of time i was just
so worried about like
oh like people on the show will
misconstrue me ooh jesus
sorry gina is back here like knocking
down our set
sorry but uh i think people just like
they put so much of what their
projection was on to me and i got tired
of it i was like well i'm just gonna say
whatever the [ __ ] i want
and i kept getting rewarded for it from
my bosses like hey you want to be on
camera now
do you want to work on this other show
you want to do this you want to do that
i was like oh
clearly i'm doing something right they
believed in you and then they saw you
starting to believe in you so then it
just
it helped it increased your career which
i think is great it's great to see
a woman break out of that like hiding
space that's i did the same [ __ ]
when i was with my ex i was just hiding
as much as i could i'm like i'm not a
cloud chaser leave me alone stop right
that's what it is
like for some reason people are just
like oh she wants attention she thinks
she's so
hot she thinks she's hot [ __ ] oh my gosh
me being with casey too same [ __ ] like
oh she slept her way into
yeah gold cookers we're like no thanks
gold diggers we didn't sleep our way
into the company they just found girls
that could also do work for them
that they could also be [ __ ] so yeah
you know
i mean yeah they they lucked out they
got a girl to have sex with they got a
girl to do work for them they got a girl
to make them look cool too you know they
lucked out too that's what i'm like hey
they're
you know and they pay us now and i've
been saying for a long time that life
really starts
when you stop giving a [ __ ] what people
think about you absolutely and just
everything you you can be your more
authentic self you can
do whatever the [ __ ] you want just not
give a [ __ ] about other people because
honestly people are more worried about
their own [ __ ] than they are
about you i have so many questions to
ask
so many can i just yeah go ahead and get
it can i can i chime into what you just
said before we get into that yeah
because i totally agree with what you're
saying and it
is the image or it is the the thought
process of like [ __ ] i don't want people
to judge me i care about what they think
but i think if you look a layer deeper
than that it's because
you care about what you think you're
judging yourself
and so like you kind of project other
people's judgments onto yourself because
it's what you are judging about yourself
i mean that's what i realized when i re
would read hate comments
and it like and then i was going to
therapy at that time and so like my i
love therapy first yeah
amazing and so like my therapist asked
me like well what is it about
what they're saying that triggers you so
much i couldn't think about it like
where is that coming from and then i
realized like
oh [ __ ] it's because i agree with them
and i'm judging myself
and so when they point out my own
insecurities or
or like what my own judgment my own
criticisms about myself it's like
holding a mirror up to myself so it
makes it even that much harder to not
care about what other people think
i think first you have to learn how to
not judge yourself
you still care about what you think
exactly when you see truth in it it
bothers you well i don't think that all
hate comments
that do trigger me are actually true
about me or that i agree with them
yeah i do think majority of it is
definitely what you're saying
probably 90 but there are still like 10
of like
shitty comments where i'm like that's
totally not based in fact or reality i
don't believe that but that still pisses
me off that like
i feel it's almost like i feel that
because someone said it
and it's in a public forum other people
are going to read it and believe it
even though it's so far from the truth
that what pisses me off is like how dare
you smear
my name but then it's like we're [ __ ]
youtubers so obviously
that's part of the job yeah that's what
you just gotta let go like you gotta let
go of the fact that knowing people are
gonna spread
complete [ __ ] about you because they
they spend five minutes on you and then
they move on to the next thing even
though it's your whole life it's only
their five minutes yeah
so they're just like kind of ruining in
your mind
your reputation but then also no one
else really [ __ ] cares yeah
true okay so i have so many questions
but first of all
tell them where you're from girl tell
them
and i would just like to say first and
foremost every single
man boy child i knew growing up
jack off to gina like
religiously wait how would you like
here's the thing no no no no because
like i watch
them talk like when i'm it i was in
middle school and this was like
around the peak of like how old are you
like more
model days of like these like asian
girls with like huge tits
like in lingerie in front of like a
[ __ ]
dope honda or whatever really thin
eyebrows and
uh yeah the thing is like huge tits
because that's where their heart is yeah
big hearts um
and everyone would be like oh it's miss
like ashley v
and then it's gina do you know she's
from the bay too yeah she's cool
and so like literally everyone's like oh
gina darling is the
perfect girl she's like from the bay
area she's hot as [ __ ] she
plays video games she's a little nerd
they'd go to the meetings and when i
found out i was on the show i was like
oh my god everyone's gonna [ __ ] freak
out when they find out
everybody i know has jacked off to you
oh including women
including women not even boys wow like
every single one of my lesbian friends
are like oh gina is hottest
santa's a dream she really is like in
the bay area you're like
you're that [ __ ] yeah you're that [ __ ]
i appreciate of san jose yay i
appreciate every orgasm that has
that has happened because of making
sense
[Applause]
right that's where i gained my power
yeah you've been sucking that power from
those men and
few women this whole time yeah so when
i'm like old and gray no one jacks off
anymore that's when i die yeah they're
like rapunzel's mom
everyone like oh i feel somebody just
unloaded a huge
knot every morning
yes sperm has been ejaculated because of
me
you just go yeah yep it's gonna be a
good day
also tell them what you're in the city
is huh tell them what your ethnicity is
i am vietnamese of course another one of
us
okay so i was really excited about that
because that's the first thing she said
she came in she's like i'm from your
hometown that makes me so happy yeah
now on to the questions um just so we
can get to know you more
when did you start only fans how long i
started only fans mid-january so i'm
still very new to it
what is like four months yeah holy [ __ ]
i'm on my fourth month right now
so um it's always kind of been a joke
because i mean everybody at some point
if you have a following regardless of
whether you're a man or woman usually
i'd say women
there's always some creepy guy saying
hey let me see your feet right always
absolutely always and i talked about it
at work and it became this bit where
it's like oh let's see cat's feet and i
would hide them religiously
wear nothing but like i will wear air
force ones to the beach
i would only show my toes when i was
like back home my mom's house and the
comfort of
that home then i'd wear sandals um
and finally i got to a point where it's
like you know what's the pandemic let's
see how far i can take this joke let's
see what
happens i'm gonna make only fancy
dedicated to my feet i
did it and it surpassed all of my
wildest dreams
yeah i then started doing uh thirst
traps because somebody dm me like hey do
you have any like
photos or videos of you that you haven't
posted on instagram but they're like
kind of hot
i was like well what are you talking
about nudes he's like no no it doesn't
have to be nudes but like
if you're wearing like a low-cut shirt
and it's just a photo of you smiling
like i'd love to pay you
x amount of money for that so i did that
and more people started asking for i was
like oh
i'm gonna do this from now on and the
mystery of not having nudes
it's just like oh what is behind that
yeah and what i found out is
i thought initially the only way you can
really make money on only fans is having
a large instagram following
because i would see girls with millions
of followers and in my head i was like
oh they must be making a absolute
killing
and uh my boyfriend who used to work in
porn
knew a lot of girls who had only friends
with millions of followers
and he said that there is a difference
where if you were on instagram prior and
you were kind of posting thirst trappy
or like
basically implied nudity before people
are less inclined to buy
from you because they've there's nothing
that you can post on your own that they
haven't already seen
on
with their case they have to kind of go
into a niche market so there are girls
who will then do like
sexy cosplays and then they'll put it on
there or they'll do
like uh cosplay porn where there's
spider-man getting [ __ ] by venom and
it's like normal cosplay like great
makeup and everything and then it
happens to be porn so people are finding
their niche markets but it's really
about
how much engagement you can get out of
your fan base and it's not just men
a lot of girls who have like primarily
women as their fan base will get these
women subscribing to their only fans
almost like an
empowerment thing like i love you so
much i want you to make money
so i will subscribe to you and pay this
amount every single month to make sure
that like i am contributing
to your success in your future so i'm
not into
girls i'm not into the photos that
you're posting but i will get on there
like all your photos hype you up and tip
you every day i love that
i love the women empowering thing
because we get that too
where like there's just women that want
to support so bad
yes and it makes me so happy because a
lot of people think like oh
your fan base is just all dudes or all
horny dudes like no we get a lot of very
loving women yeah in fact my most active
viewers on my stream
are all women really yeah and it's
beautiful and i love that that's
absolutely amazing
yeah um so i
okay so i remember always getting
messages for my feet but they were so
specific like
can you show your yours you're the
bottom of your feet your soul's crystals
are the money makers that's right what
people
don't tell you people don't tell you
they think it's like this area of the
foot where you see the toes
it's the money makers are your souls
they want to see how
soft they are and so like if you lather
them up with some sort of coconut oil or
baby oil and then you put lotion on them
wait for them to dry off you take a
photo and people want to essentially
have your soft so that's how you step on
their feet on their face
on their body they're just like it's
soft i want it to touch me
get that on like very weirdly thinking
about a soft
foot i can kind of get it
like does it make sense to you yeah i
think like this is like
an extremely lotioned and soft
foot or even the hand like i just really
i really do enjoy very
soft hands so i imagine poor foot
yes because you would make a kill in
gina jesus your hands are
the softest [ __ ] hands i've ever
heard they're very very nice she's very
feminine hands too yeah
i've got to hide these [ __ ]
from now on mittens everywhere i go you
guys gotta pay for this [ __ ]
well if you do need a stylist we have
stitch fix here for you um
online shopping can be daunting you
never know if things will fit returns
can be difficult and you don't even know
what sort of
store to start with so this season let
stitch fix do all the hard work
i have used stitch fix a few times
already myself i
like the personal the i like to be able
to also go to the website and pick
certain things too because they create
like whole outfits on their website and
put pictures of the whole
outfit together so that's what helps me
because i i can find pieces that i like
like just a top
or just jeans that i like but i never
know how to match things so yeah i like
one part of their website is that they
will put outfits together and you can
just buy specific things or you can buy
the whole outfit or you can just have
this stylist
um curate a whole box for you i like how
it comes with the thing where it shows
you different outfit ideas yeah that you
can use
yeah so like they'll send you a top and
then they'll show you how to put a
cardigan over it or a sweater or like a
different jacket or different shoes or
just have it go from night to day or day
or whatever
so it's very helpful when if you're
terrible at fashion like me i'm horrible
at fashion
um so yeah it's gotten really good yeah
i know it's very very basic and it's the
same and very lateral so
don't compliment don't compliment me
because i know it's crap
um anyways try on pieces at home before
you buy keep what you love and return
what you don't stitch fix has free
shipping easy returns and exchanges
with the prepaid return envelope
included makes it very very simple
i love that because i will not ship
something out for months just because
you have to go get the label and then
you have to go do all that yeah um
stitch fix um you just pay a 20 styling
fee for each box but it gets credited
towards the pieces you keep
and there are no hidden fees ever they
have styles and clothing to fit any
occasion for men women and kids they
ship all over the u.s
as well as the uk get started today at
stitchfix.com
mood and you'll get 25 off when you keep
everything in your fix
that's stitchfix.com mood for 25
off when you keep everything in your fix
stitchfix.com
mood and if you have a nice outfit you
can't be having a janky smile to go with
it no
are your teeth throwing up gang signs
well do i have something for you we have
candid candid is the clear comfortable
removable and practically invisible
aligners to help straighten teeth
it's here to help straighten your teeth
so you can fall in love with your smile
too
i wish i had this when i was a kid yeah
braces the wiry braces
the head gear stuck in there yeah yeah
it's just horrible
you know water you can remove the rubber
bands
i used to have the white ones because
they i thought they made my teeth look
white and then they would turn yellow
yeah the clear ones the clear bridge
yeah the clear band the white bands
clearly oh cause i had
clear braces like they weren't metal
they were made of acrylic but the wire
was clear i mean
the wire was metal and yeah the white
bands
they would actually turn my freaking it
just looks yellow gross yeah
it looks so gross you're not fooling
anyone yeah the whole traditional braces
process
that's why we have candid you can remove
them and pop them back on
uh your treatment is prescribed and
closely monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert
in tooth movement you'll have the same
quality of care you'd get in an
in-office orthodontist from the comfort
and convenience of your home
and while other companies use general
dentists candid only works with
orthodontists
with candid the same orthodontist who
created your plan
is with you from start to finish so you
never have to wonder how you're doing
the average candid treatment is just six
months you'll start seeing results way
before then
and it costs a thousand dollars less
than traditional braces become your best
you start straightening your teeth today
right now you can save 75 dollars on
candids starter kit go to candidco.com
mood and use code mood that's
candidco.com
mood code mood take advantage of this
limited time offered to save
75 on your starter kit candid co that's
candid co.com mood code
mood have you had a chance to really
understand the psychology behind the
foot thing or if you're just like i
don't [ __ ] know but here you go pay
me
some people have explained it to me in
several different ways um
there was one guy who scientifically
broke it down was like there's
a wiring in a man's brain who's in
defeat
where it kind of resembles a vagina for
some reason and so when they see
feet they associate it with the vagina
and that's why it's sexual
and other people are like it's just soft
i don't get it
i just wanna know it's like a foot yeah
i can't imagine
at all
because they want like your foot to do
this
that's really what it is i've seen like
foot job stuff
like this a [ __ ] that's where he got
his name from only fantastic yeah
i think that's technically called joy
which is jerk off instruction
so uh yeah a lot of people in the feet
community want
joy videos where it's basically like
your foot doing the fussy
and then you have like a water bottle an
eggplant some sort of like
cylindrical dick like shape thing
and then you talk about jacking off this
thing with your feet
hmm i do not do that i don't have the
guts too i'm like oh that's a bit
that's right i can't do it without
laughing like
exactly yeah like i don't know how to
tip with your big toes
that's too funny yeah what about like
foot
sucking stuff do you guys like getting
your feet your toes i
haven't had my foot or toes sucked on
until recently
and it was almost like a joke because i
was ignoring my boyfriend and he was
trying to get my attention
and he randomly just like he just like
grabbed my foot and he put it in his
mouth
and i didn't register what was going on
because i was on my phone and i just
like moved it down
[Laughter]
and i couldn't like i was in shock for
about two seconds i didn't know what to
do
just like oh yeah no i just showered it
was a clean
foot and then i like took it out like
how
what i might like this now i might like
this i don't know what it is and i
honestly i did like him i like it too
it's a better sensation than i thought
yeah it really is it tickles but
it feels kind of nice it's like warm i
wonder
if that's what guys feel like their dick
feels like in a vagina
oh like if that's
why are you so gross though don't yuck
somebody's young
don't you use my line against me you
don't do that
do you know where you're being a
hypocrite i have had it done once
yeah and i'm not the type that's going
to be like oh hey can you stop because i
don't want to ruin the moment
so he did do it he just didn't do it
right or something i mean like it was
it happened to me twice right so once it
was just like in the middle of sex i'm
like you know what if you're into that
it's fine go ahead i'm not going to stop
you for me it's just like oh okay
i'm gonna pretend that i like it you
know and then there was another guy that
did it that
the thing is i was just really into him
so i yeah he was just like he could do
anything
yeah so he's never done it before he's
like and we were in the bathtub he's
like
does this do anything for you i'm like i
mean not that that's working
but the fact that you're doing it yes so
you need to get a guy that's
confident about it he's like no i'm
sucking these toes yeah
like you don't want a shy guy kind of
like going around the bush
that was the first one that was the
first one he was really into it mm-hmm
and you know i'm just like but maybe
he's doing it for too long it's only
needs to do it for like 15 seconds
not like a long time no most awkward
what was it that you were feeling
like what was it for you that it was
just like i don't like this
i just don't i'm not into feet you know
like
you like you were grossed out by your
like the dirtiness of your
foot in his mouth i just don't like feet
that's all mm-hmm
even your own like you're just trying to
i got cute feet i like my feet i just
don't
what about getting a foot massage or
something like like like
because for me getting my toes sucked
it's kind of like that it's like it's
relaxing but i could also get turned on
by
because he's turned on by it right but
but it's like
i i wouldn't like just getting my toes
sucked
isn't gonna turn me on exactly you know
so that's why i'm asking like
are you able to get pleasure or
relaxation from like your feet
being in someone's mouth just like a
foot massage
just like not sexually just relaxation i
want to know that
i think it's more of a in the moment
kind of thing i know i don't know
like what jess was saying it just feels
like yeah like the inside of the mouth
is all warm
yeah and so like yes the inside of a
cheek is very soft i mean i'm like when
they get their dick sucked i'm like
that that probably feels pretty good
because like the inside of your cheeks
you're really selling me on this foot
sucking thing
you're absolutely right because now that
i think of it like
that like 10 seconds or something but it
was kind of like you know when guys get
so [ __ ] excited they're just like i'm
just gonna [ __ ] whatever i'm gonna
yeah eat it whatever it is i don't care
you know it's just like one of those
moments
but you're also talking to someone who
grew up in a vietnamese family they had
nail salons so i've seen the crusties
that they have
you know mm-hmm so it's just like i'm
not gonna yeah you guys have like a
thing with feet yeah yeah just not my
thing interesting yeah
have you had any so i'm so curious have
you had any
extremely weird strange requests for
things to do with your feet
uh with my feet yeah it's well
i guess weird is kind of relative to
everybody
but for me like i never wan i don't like
the idea of me like sucking on my own
toes or licking my feet
and some people are really into that
that's a great thumbnail
[Laughter]
but yeah so it's a really big part of
the feet community to
lick and suck on your own toes and i'm
just not into that so i find that weird
but then i'll have other requests like
some people are into armpits some people
are into like the back of your knees
so people are into belly buttons there's
a lot of different things that people
are into
that i never would have even imagined
would be sexual
yeah like how is an armpit sexual unless
you're like i mean i think they're just
so
burnt out on porn yeah they're like
trying to find something exciting
because they've been burnt out since 14.
let me stick it in your ear yeah right
there like it was all downhill after
they came to gina
they were like now i need armpits armpit
there's nothing else exciting in life
they start doing the weird [ __ ]
now i want to talk to like only fans
armpit girls like what's the is there
like a niche like no like could i
be an army
[Music]
like do they like show you should i be
free i think it depends on preference
because i had a guy who wanted a photo
of my armpit
while it was as natural as possible he
asked me to grow it out he asked me to
shave it he just won it in different
stages
wow so like i throughout the week i
would like not shave
on purpose to get as long as i could to
send him and then he tipped me extra
because i had to grow it out but they're
just like stubbles
yeah you get to like to the hair starts
to curl
stage or you know you just you know it's
just like a week i was like
you know what i'll put up with it for a
week and then after that i just
personally feel gross i don't i need to
shave it
dude you would be disappointed with me
because i lasered yeah
it's like three hairs yeah yeah yeah it
dries everything off now
i just i don't want to deal with body
hair but it's weird because when you
laser you know how they
only get certain patches you got to go
back and when it starts growing out
suddenly like it looks weird
yeah it's like whiskers yeah that's what
i'm getting with my bikini line right
now so like there's certain parts that
are patches and some of them are just
bald
it creeps me out because i remember the
first time i got lasered i could
actually
pull the follicle out and i swear
to the bathtub and i was like what the
[ __ ] that sounds like my dream i love
like popping blackheads and like
plucking hairs it's just like vietnamese
sounds like right after you get the
laser done like i would say within the
week
like it shocked the hair follicle and
then and then it dies so then you it
just
like you could just start pulling them
out duct tape just slapped on there just
duct tape no that did that gets rid of
all the fun you can sit there
and do one at a time you don't
understand i remember doing that like
when i first got lazy i'll be watching
tv just
they just fall out it's [ __ ]
disgusting right now you just have a
pile of your pubes just on your
face that is so disgusting
it's like your [ __ ] went through chemo
here's the thing if you can make asian
jokes because he's with the asian girl i
can make cancer jokes and well i mean
i don't know if he should be making
asian jokes but
i did the same thing though when i was
with my ex i was making asian jokes and
then after i was like oh that's
actually wildly inappropriate see but
that's like in the sanctity of your
relationship
yeah and like you guys know each other
it's not like he's going around making
like
jokes he got me doing fab accents in the
house
and then people would be like don't
forget you can't say that out in public
and i'm like oh yeah
like don't don't do this it's like
contagious though because it
is like hanging around with them so much
like i started doing it on my own or
like oh [ __ ]
wait i didn't used to say this word this
way i mean how long have i called you
jessica until i had to like learn
i was like i know sometimes it almost
accidentally comes out i'm like
yeah but we just go with jess now yeah
yes but anyway how often do you get
pedicures um
i'd say once every three to four weeks
depending on my schedule
i just feel like i can't do the thing
that some girls do where they change it
every week or every
oh yeah the other week it's just like
it's so much work and on top of that you
can only do so many [ __ ] colors so
you're like i i have nothing left
it's true do you get requests for like
natural
now like no pedicure yeah a lot of
people like different things some people
like
darker uh polish some people like
lighter some people want neon
they want designs some people like matte
coat so does anyone ask you to put like
extensions on your toes
oh my god no but here's the thing my
grandma has yes my grandma has acrylic
and she's had acrylic toenails for years
and we just never
knew my grandma my grandma is like super
girly where she always has to have her
hair done her nails done but i didn't
know she had acrylic toenails too
like all of them are just all of them
they wouldn't be like super long or
anything but like they're
why would you want fake toenails i don't
you know that weird tiny pinky toenail
that some people just some people don't
even have a
pinky toenail yeah yeah they're just
like pink skin yeah
[Music]
if i cut mine it's like really tiny same
same i'm not sure i haven't told you
i'll fall off once because i wore heels
for so long
do you have a request for janky ass feet
janky feet uh
not janky feet but dirty feet oh uh
but i just i don't feel good about
putting
like making my feet dirty i don't know
if it's because like the asian
like clean feet like in the house like i
don't like having my feet dirty so i
always have the
the inclination to clean it at all times
if it feels even slightly dusty what if
you did a video of
like you got your foot all like nasty
and dirty in the mud and then like your
boyfriend i know he doesn't or
he probably doesn't want to be on your
only fans but he was like cleaning them
off do you think that would be
sexual washing that could kind of like a
jesus moment you know like wash your
hands i want to step on things now
because i saw a video of a girl stepping
on cake for a minute and that just
looked like i
want to do that for free like i just
messed up on cake or like do a paper if
you wear slaps
make wine and chicken and then sell the
juice to people oh
like the bell dolphin thing yeah that's
genius i just want to step on cake i
also want to smash cakes with baseball
bats
like that gwen stefani video yeah i
really want to i really want to smash
somebody asked me to crush a small
watermelon with my thighs
that i want to try do you really think
you have the thigh tensile strength for
that
yeah you gotta cheat it you gotta cheat
it i gotta cut you kind of like
squish it first and then pretend like
yeah yeah
i just think it will be fun like
invisible holes all the way around it in
a circle yeah
or have you seen those videos where
people will put rubber bands around
watermelon until they explode
do that and then take them off and then
squeeze it i saw one guy get
it exploded and it hit him and he flew
off his chair i [ __ ] died laughing
he flew that she was so good oh my god
that's amazing so
how do you prevent people from just
saving the photos and uploading it for
free somewhere else on some real [ __ ]
that happens
and that happens to absolutely everybody
it's i think it's a
part of the game that you do but there
are law firms or not law firms there are
companies that will actually take down
those images for you if you pay them a
retainer fee yeah so that's something
that a lot of only fans girls will look
into some
because it's copyright yeah it's copy
written yeah and then it's on youtube
just for regular [ __ ] like
depending on companies for copyright
depending on what state you're in that
also
classifies as uh revenge porn so you can
actually have a misdemeanor or a felony
on your record if somebody chooses to
follow up with that how does that
how's that revenge porn when that's just
something you sold
i'm not sure somebody was trying to
explain it to me where it's like
it's your intellectual property but it's
sexual so in certain states it does
qualify as revenge porn well
i mean i appreciate that but yeah but
yeah absolutely i think it's just
something you gotta kind of roll with
the punches on some girls will leave it
up because they think it's
good pr for them and they're just like
oh it's like advertisement at this point
so some girls will let certain ones go
like oh yeah they'll have a free one
on reddit and some girls like no take
absolutely everything down
and so it just kind of depends on what
helps you make money because if
the leaks are hurting you then it's in
your best interest to
hire someone to take them down or file
certain
claims on google to have these images
taken down whereas some girls it
actually helps them so they're like
there's no point in me trying to even
try to take a leak down all right how
about for you in your experience
uh it's kind of 50 50. i feel like i'm
still so new to it that i don't
know what a normal like
month should be i'm getting to that
point where it's starting to kind of
even
out now i mean i i think if leaks ever
get to the point where i'm starting to
lose money then i'll look into
having like a firm take down those
photos or if there's just a
high volume of your stuff getting yeah
for free
yeah because uh i know like i feel like
every single girl who has and only fans
has a reddit page dedicated to them
where it's like
oh here it is as people like oh should i
buy this one should i buy this one don't
waste your money here it is
and so that tends to happen a lot but at
that point it's like
it's the internet it kind of comes with
the territory so you can either
hire somebody to go and take them down
or you can leave it up
it's really just dependent on you all
right dude shout out to
our sponsor function of beauty i
freaking love this company so much it's
so easy for me
to shout them out because it's all i've
been using on my hair for the past two
years and i
love it it's night and day difference
but they are the world leader in fully
customized hair care
you basically you go on their website
you fill out a hair quiz so you tell
them what kind of hair you have like
straight curly
thick thin you know whatever to help
virgin and uh you let them know what
your hair goals are so if you want more
shine
volume strength you know whatever that
is and they'll put together a custom
formula for you
there's over like how many trillions
there's like
50 trillion it doesn't say on here but
there's i've read it before there's
hundreds of trillions of different
combinations they can do so you're
getting
a unique custom design for your hair uh
every product is sulfate and paraben
free vegan cruelty free and there are
over 60 000
real five-star customer reviews i'm like
five of those
i'm on the peach scent right now you can
customize your your your
scent your color all of that they even
put your name on the bottle i have a
christmas cookie scent it's really good
it's delicious
but it's sold out now so you can't get
it can't get it sorry
[Applause]
go to functionalbeauty.com to take your
quiz and save 20
on your first order that applies to
their full range of customized hair
skin and body products that's
functionalbeauty.com
big mood to let them know you heard
about it here and to get 20
off your order function of beauty.com
big mood
food and while you're
enjoying your luscious beautiful hair
and your nice soft skin you want to put
that skin
and that beautiful hair on a nice
comfortable mattress right
yes yes that's where purple comes in
so you guys know i've had purple for a
long time now and it's such a reliable
mattress i absolutely love it
and that's because purple is comfort
reinvented purple has the grid
which is the only mattress that has this
particular technology
which is a stretchy gel material that's
amazingly supportive for your back and
legs
while cushioning your shoulders neck and
hips
i don't know how it does it but it is
fantastic i absolutely love this
mattress i highly recommend it
and the grid doesn't trap air it's
actually
circulating the air like it allows it to
flow
and circulate through the entire
mattress so you'll never feel overheat
so purple is comfortable for an
uncomfortable world
right now you'll get 10 off any order
that's 200
or more go to purple.com big mood 10 and
use promo code bigmood10
that's purple.com bigmood10
promo code bigmuten for 10 off any order
of 200
or more one last time it's purple.com
big mood 10 promo code big mood 10
terms apply how has your life changed
since you started
like improved or negative how has it
changed it's get
open more doors for you are you more
financially like comfortable
are you more like you [ __ ] i like
your purse by the way oh thank you
i'm definitely more financially
independent now um
wait let's say the purse what's the
purse i have a like a nano celine bag
oh that's expensive yeah i i call it my
money bag
yeah the first like nice thing i bought
with the only fan's money
but um i think it's allowed me to have a
lot of financial
security and freedom because now i'm not
kind of
reliant on anyone to like give me a
paycheck
so even though in the long run only fans
does hurt certain girls
and creators if their end goal is to be
in a professional setting like if you're
trying to be a doctor
a lawyer an accountant working like a
normal like company job
even though the stigma of only fans is
slowly starting to die out it's still
very like with these
normal companies kind of look down upon
and so you hear a lot of girls who used
to be emts get fired from their jobs
because they're trying to make up for
like the pandemic teachers
that's something i don't understand like
society where
women and men we're telling girls that
this is empowering
but then you see that where it affects
your other career process like if you're
not going to be in entertainment forever
that then you're going to be kind of
[ __ ] so that's that's the only thing
that i struggle with a little bit where
i'm like well i am
getting my cpa license and i want to be
a professional so
as much as like i feel like that'd be
cool for now it's like it follows you
forever so that's the only thing
so do you feel like you you knew that
you were going to just stay in
entertainment forever so that wasn't
really a concern for you yes i
learned very quickly after i graduated
from college that working a corporate
job
wasn't for me and i i just i couldn't do
it i'm not one of those people who have
that personality whereas my sister
she thrives in that type of setting yeah
and so every now and then when she
kind of like gets down on her luck with
when it comes to like
having hours taken away from her at work
because everyone's trying to work during
a pandemic
she's like oh maybe only fence would be
a good option as a side gig and i have
to remind her like
although only fans is great it isn't for
everyone and i'm not somebody who's just
gonna recommend that you do only fans so
you could get a quick check you got to
really look at
what the big picture is of what you want
to do if you want to go in the medical
field this probably isn't going to be
a great side hustle for you there are
other things you can do you can do door
dash you can
do uh like all this [ __ ] that makes no
money yeah
there are different things if you need
like a little bit of money for
like a quick check there are other ways
you can do it that you
absolutely do not have to do cost you
more in the long run yeah even though
you might get it you gotta think big
pictures
of 40 years you got to think about as
you age every decade
yeah is that going to follow not even
just yourself but who how is it going to
affect your
like people around you like for example
your kids because that's that's why i
think twice three times before
like wanting to jump on this because i
am really curious and i think i'd be
down
and not not do what other people might
think that i would be doing on only fans
i'll tell you after i like your
idea i have a really good idea i know
people who do magic on only fans so it's
not all sexual
no yeah but magic no it's a guy who does
magic and he's really good
that's awesome okay that'd be dope like
look i just made an orange appear in my
titties like she's still naked but she's
still doing
makeup that'd be sick is my [ __ ] lip
cramped or is it
we did a news article once um on this
one mom who got
like her her kids got kicked out of
school because of her daughter it was in
private school right yeah it was a
private school yeah
so i'm like dude you don't know like how
that could affect you [ __ ] haters man
right the other parents it's probably
because all the other dads are paying
for it
and i can see that because i'm saltiest
if i have a boyfriend and he's paying
for an only fan sorry i will be kind of
salty i'm like
that's where single man i think single
man can spend all the money they want
well attack your husband don't attack
her no
no absolutely i'm saying they're
definitely [ __ ] haters but i
get in the mentality of being upset
about it but not to [ __ ]
like don't ever actually bring the woman
down it's more about the system that
you're angry at right
yes the woman leave the woman alone dude
you know what's another thing too that
makes me think
like rethink this yeah thing is um so
like a lot of
my income is from working with brands
and like
family friendly brands like disney for
example they just invited us to go to
disneyland yesterday like i don't i
wouldn't want to lose
those partnerships by starting something
like this either
absolutely so even if it's like not
sexual because
my thing is what i'm thinking of is not
sexual
crazy i mean it is technically but
anyway
i don't want to give it away food it's
not good yeah it's not naked
or even thirst trap stuff but anyway
it's just by
being on that platform already has a
stigma so i'm like i wouldn't want to
lose
relationships when that disney money
dries up then you go to only
it's also i feel like a little different
at least because
i am an only fans creator i kind of know
the direction that they're trying to
take with the company they're trying to
go
very like when you think
of what is like snapchat was originally
used for what like sending nudes real
quick and then you don't
like it disappears and so does the
conversation now people use it like
they're a snapchat
oh it doesn't actually disappear it
doesn't actually disappear
right you're right it doesn't um but uh
only fans are actually trying to launch
it where
it is friendlier and now they're
launching like only fans tv which is
kind of their
version of uh like youtube and so there
are a lot of
people on there who have perfect for my
idea by the way
like only fans pages and people can
subscribe to it without paying and they
it's basically like a free patreon page
where
instead of going onto patreon or going
on to youtube you go on to online
watch you watch the content absolutely
for free and then
because it's free you can have the
option of doing locked posts so say
there's a girl who tries anything yeah
on patreon just like patreon
basically post public stuff or stuff
behind the pay wall yeah because a lot
of uh fitness people will do workouts on
there and say like oh here's a quick
uh video of my workout from today and
then they'll post another one where
for ten dollars you could get this
workout plan that i did i explained to
you
everything or i can give you my
nutrition plan
for 15 and you can buy it and the page
is still free but if you want to see the
extra stuff then you pay
and so it's kind of a way to show people
like hey
i'm not like doing anything like sneaky
or shady it's all family friendly
because
it is free and you can see that i'm
clearly not doing these things but at
the same time like
it's just with where only fan is right
now it still does have that stigma so
working with certain
with certain brands it does get very
tricky patreon
i think did a good job of um changing
their branding because i think patreon
also started out it was like a lot of
sex workers and stuff
yeah but now everyone feels like patreon
is totally
a normal brand so i feel like maybe if
you just give a little bit of time maybe
the
yeah the vibe of it will change does
your family know what you do
oh absolutely they're things they're
like crazy so
supportive and so many people i i think
it's because they probably come from
like uh
more conservative families that are like
oh like they must be so ashamed that
you're doing this like
first of all my dad gave me the a okay
he's like you should absolutely do it
you should absolutely [ __ ] do it like
if people are going to sexualize you
anyways make money off of that
why would you not my mom's like yeah
it's probably good that it's not like
full-on [ __ ] in your face
porn yeah you can make a little a lot of
money with not even
taking your clothes off yeah go ahead
girl yeah and my
family uh they have a lot of vietnamese
coffee shops which is like girls in
bikinis or like
lingerie walking around serving coffee
and so i kind of come from that world
anyways so my family like nobody my
uncles my aunts my grandparents they
don't see anything wrong with what i'm
doing but because again
like you said like the projection that
people have of like who you
are and what you should or shouldn't be
doing they're like oh they're ashamed of
you this and that like my dad tells me
every single day
as long as you're gonna buy me my dream
car at the end of the year like we're
all good
don't make your feet money i can imagine
your grandmother like taking photos for
you like
or arch arch a little bit more yeah
she's like hey sucking sucking
yeah yeah you look great i love it
[Laughter]
but like my family really doesn't care
what i do they're like you're making
good money and with that money like i
help my family pay off their debt
so that's another thing that i don't
think people have like even think of
is like i'm not just making money and
like blowing it on [ __ ] like sports
cars and [ __ ] like i'm helping paying
off
like family debt that's what people
assume about sex workers a lot that they
just
make all this money blown on drugs and
[ __ ] whatever but i mean a lot of
them do
a lot of them do but there's also a
really good amount like my girlfriend
she is a sex worker and she lives
in like the nicest apartment in san
francisco but she also
invested a bunch she started her own
apps she paid off her parents debt like
they they do this for family too it's
not just all just frivolous spending on
[ __ ]
because i feel like they think like oh
sex workers are
just dumb girls who could never make it
in the corporate world or we're not
smart enough to go to school whatever
but no these are actually a lot of very
intelligent women
who are investing it properly who know
what they're doing they're not like dumb
bimbos running around
absolutely that's the thing that like i
don't think people talk enough about
when it comes to sex workers a lot of
people who make fun of like strippers
for instance if you go to like
any large city like atlanta where they
have or like new jersey with uh what's
it called magic city city girls yeah
those girls are making so much [ __ ]
money and a lot of the
like some of them yeah like they'll blow
in they're not spending it properly
a lot of them have multiple rental
properties multiple investments
like these are business women just the
way that they have found a way to
monetize
off of the way they look that's it
people don't like the idea that you can
monetize off of your sexuality
exactly for some reason like they're
okay if like models do it but then if
you're doing it for sex work they don't
think it's the same thing
they're like oh no it's different you're
not like actual model even though you're
doing the same thing and selling photos
of yourself
right and they're like oh what would
your kids think like my kids in a
[ __ ] private school right now
you know so i think it's fine yeah yeah
i
it's always i always see those those
comments
online just like just thinking that
they're so [ __ ] stupid
it's like oh you're just a stripper no
she's a stripper with [ __ ] 20 rental
properties you know you think she gives
a [ __ ] laughing to the bank
no that's awesome so do you
i mean like yes i run out of content do
you ever run out of like ideas like what
the [ __ ] i'm gonna do with my feet today
you know like
have you ever tried holding your toes
together oh yeah oh my god i have not i
think i did it as like a joke
before yeah like you hold for you
[ __ ]
yeah you interlocked yourself it's such
a it's a kid thing even i isaac just did
it the other day i
never even thought that ever to do that
and everyone's done that oh i did it
with like a significant other wants to
joke around and we just could not stop
laughing that's the most
awkward feeling ever but it's so [ __ ]
funny because like your body knows it's
not supposed to do that yeah
right now yeah cut to me like i need my
hands i need my hands
yeah so do you ever like the [ __ ] am i
gonna absolutely i think
with stuff like that i'm kind of lucky
in that my fan base tells me what they
want to see
usually they're very vocal about like oh
this would be great i would love to see
this and instead of charging them like a
for a pay-per-view which would be more
expensive i say okay thanks for the idea
i'll actually post it on the main wall
so
everyone can kind of see this content so
they'll tell me what they want most of
the time
which is really nice because at the end
of the day it's a foot how many things
can you do with the future
right apparently a lot but i i just
don't have the mind for it
what's your favorite kind of post to
post
uh i think feet is my favorite right now
just because it's so easy
it's really simple to just get like kind
of
lather up your feet and do a video of
you just washing it for 10 minutes
or like i'm watching tv and i have like
my feet on the table and the camera's
right there and i'm just like wiggling
my toes for five minutes
that's what people want to see and then
in the background they're like oh you're
watching that podcast or like you're
watching the show i love it
and it then goes into other avenues of
me talking to them about whatever the
[ __ ]
yeah because this is what keeps up
engagement yeah isn't that mainly
the connection that a lot of these guys
that signed up for these kind of
platforms look for is like
for like past the sexual part yeah
they're looking for
companionship yeah friendship it really
is because i'll start off
like doing thirst traps or whatever or
stuff with my feet and then
eventually i'm talking to this guy who's
in oklahoma talking about like oh i'm
gonna buy my first
uh house and i'm really excited i just
actually got
my uh degree yesterday i'm graduating
soon
uh i can't be on here for too long
because i'm a broke college student but
i'm actually uh
trying to be a lawyer and this now i'm
like oh good for you so i get
a lot of people who kind of come and go
and i know there's one guy who left like
hey
pandemic's rough i'll be back in the
next few months and then he came back
it's like
oh my god i have a girlfriend she's the
best thing ever she watches the podcast
with you i'm like oh this is
surprisingly so wholesome some girls
will give
will have my only fans with their
boyfriend like they'll send me stuff
well i guess if they're your fan
yeah that makes sense yeah but i get so
annoyed when guys have [ __ ] only fans
and their girlfriends are like what the
[ __ ]
you won't take me out to dinner but
you're paying for seven accounts not
only for the amount
of girls who don't know that their
boyfriends have only fans
and then like will message me afterwards
like hey sweetie i'm like
i don't know what your life is doing
that's not my fault yeah it all starts
with hey girly
yeah always great hey babe yeah
it's your fault i don't get that it's
not your fault it's
always the guy's fault and it's like
don't [ __ ] attack the only fans girls
that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah i didn't ask him to be here that's
the part that's annoying though is
because they are trying to get that
personal connection right like they're
trying to message you and like tell you
about their life and get that like
bedside manner thing from like
you're in a [ __ ] relationship why are
you doing that yeah absolutely i think
it has to be
or at least for me like i'd be so
annoyed if my boyfriend had an
only fans account he's messaging other
girls without me knowing like it's one
thing if
he told me like hey this is what i want
to do this just what i like to do
in my spare time if i was okay with it
cool if i'm not like don't like
what is the issue like am i not
fulfilling something with you that you
feel like you need to go
to an outside source to get whatever
satisfaction this thing
is do you feel i mean i don't know tell
me if i'm wrong but to me it feels like
emotional cheating in a way where i know
like guys
you're hiding it absolutely sex from
love and all that and i get that like
they can literally love their wife
and then [ __ ] someone else i get that
but like it feels like cheating to me i
don't know
i feel like it's cheating when you hide
it but if you're not hiding it and
you're open about it i then don't really
count as cheating but it's
think though that guys can manipulate
the girl into being okay with it even if
they're not that's where i draw i'm just
kind of like i don't know yeah
absolutely
oh look this is what i do you know it
but it's what i do and the girl just has
to be like
okay yeah go ahead have fun
relationships with models and that's the
girl that that falls on the girl then i
know
like they just need to be stronger and
like walk away if they're not
okay with that i feel like i've had that
i've seen that with like
men though too where they will have a
really attractive girlfriend that they
feel like
they're just kind of lucky to be there
with her that they
are then okay with her like getting
flown out by someone else because
yeah like just doing all these other
things that he usually wouldn't be okay
with but
in his head he's like oh well like she
loves me she comes home to me
at the end of the day they're not like
really okay with it but it's almost like
having parts of her is better than not
having her at all i think that's what it
is with certain girls too
like that emotional manipulation of like
you know what i should just be happy
that i'm the one i'm his number one i'm
the one who comes home
i don't agree with her i don't agree
with that yeah that's really sad but
yeah
i've seen that before like those those
snarky posts that women was like yeah he
might be bubba
with you but he comes home to me i'm
like you're proud of that like you're
okay with that
like if that's something you're
absolutely okay with then that's 100
fine but chances are if you're posting
on instagram you're not okay with it
yeah yeah
if you have a black screen on your ig
story and you type out that [ __ ]
you are not okay with it right yeah
because that's something like you do in
private then
you don't have to blast it out and i
don't i don't uh definitely don't look
down on girl like i think it's just like
a just
they've their environment created that
and they're a victim of that
so i i'm not coming down i've honestly
like i will always put a woman above
anything like whatever situation she's
and i understand we have a lot of [ __ ]
to go through so yeah i get it yeah
so the whole aspect of dating someone
who used to do porn yeah
oh my gosh i would be so jealous i would
be like oh my god
i wanted nothing to [ __ ] do with this
man when i first met him
he was he is a friend of my bosses
because he is a comic as well
and i in my two years of working there
i've never met him but i've always heard
like these crazy stories because he's
lived a very like
insane almost unfortunate life like he
had
he had a like shitty upbringing with his
family he grew up in boston he was
selling drugs as a kid he had cancer
when he was like 17. that you can joke
about now that i can joke about him
lymphatic i believe and he never he
didn't go to a doctor he wasn't close
with his family and he was rushed to the
hospital and found out like hey you
probably have only a few months to live
and he ended up surviving and shortly
after that he went to prison for nine
years because he was dealing drugs
and then he got out and he didn't know
what to do with his life started
doing comedy and i started doing porn
and that and to me i was like oh he's
like this like
former felon [ __ ] boys just out here
like [ __ ] porn stars or whatever how
did you get to
trust him i met him and he's the most
wholesome
man i've ever met in my life all he
wants to do is go to home goods while
he's holding my hand
and ask me if i want to treat before we
go home like you want to stop get boba
stop that's so cute he's so [ __ ] cute
and wholesome people give me so much
[ __ ] for dating him because he's a he
was a
porn star but it's like he is the
kindest man
i know he's like the type of guy to if
we are
out somewhere and drinking he'll always
check up on me like do you need water
are you hungry do you want to go home
do your feet hurt do you want me to pull
up the car so you don't have to walk
this and that like he is like the most
romantic man i've ever met
and he's so cute but at first i thought
it was like him putting on like a facade
like a love-bombing thing yeah like a
love-bombing thing which i was so
worried about like oh this
[ __ ] boy knows how cuz i mean [ __ ] boys
can love bomb to the [ __ ] end of the
earth i mean
they're so good they're so good at it so
many times
yeah yeah but then he just like he
constantly showed up
even though like i've kept him yeah like
at a distance he just kept showing up
and showing up like hey do you need
anything
like i know you don't like me but uh if
you want to go to dinner
like can we go yeah he was like a school
boy he followed me around like he was a
lost puppy and he was like an older guy
he's like nine years older than me so i
thought he was full of [ __ ]
just trying to like [ __ ] a young girl
yeah i mean for me
red flag but it sounds like he might be
you know a little different than the
stereotype yeah absolutely i think it's
because he had like a
weird upbringing with his family that he
just kind of wanted someone to love
yeah so he was like hi will you take me
in will you adopt me
and that's how like i i'm with him now
he's met my family my family loves him
it's just like this whole thing where
people have this
idea that like my family hates him
because he did porn and he's a felon and
like now i'm an only fan but he probably
made you do that he's pimping you out
and he's like babe do you want me to
respond to dms for you if you're
stressing out today
just tell me what you want to say i'll
type it in do you need me to record
something for your feet
do you want a treat i'll go leave the
room and grab you some popcorn chicken
if you want i'm like
oh i love you that is really cute i mean
we're vietnamese
so wholesome we're vietnamese we have a
few felons in every family
absolutely yeah absolutely it's almost
as if you can't judge people by what the
[ __ ] they put on the internet
in media you dumbasses yeah it's also
like everyone has a different upbringing
like
who am i or anyone else to judge him for
his choices when he didn't have a lot
to go off of will he open together uh
for
i met him last may so only like a few
months i think he and i were like
boyfriend girlfriend
in november i we were in nashville for a
sho
for a comedy show i got really drunk and
i was like i love you
he's like oh i've known i love you for
so long like why didn't you [ __ ] tell
me
he's like because i like you more i need
you to have one thing that you give me
that's so i was like oh okay that's cute
that's really sweet but yeah i think
it's just like about trust
yeah trust communication just knowing
that like at the end of the day
he's not a guy who's going to take
advantage of it yeah i mean as long as
you feel taken care of then
for sure but how about the um like do
you get
um i guess the word is jealous but like
do you get jealous of his
past even though you weren't part of it
and obviously logically but i'm talking
about it emotionally
i think at first i kind of was because
in my head he's more attractive than me
and so i need to see a picture of this
man he's like
you're working hard oh thank you he's
like a short blonde king in my hand he's
like
uh he's just i don't know like he's very
he takes care of himself very well and
in my head i'm like
not attractive at all i'm like the bro
excuse you
yeah i think it's being just like a low
self-esteem thing from when i was a
child
i
you're like not even wearing makeup are
you i have eyebrows on your skin is like
her skin milk but it's just i don't know
like i always thought that i was like
ugly and so when i saw him like
everything from like my childhood came
back i was like oh i'm not attractive
he's not gonna like me he [ __ ] porn
stars
and then it got to a point where i was
like
oh like he has so many girlfriends that
like he knew from when he was in vegas
and like vegas girls are [ __ ]
beautiful yeah i get that and and so i
was like yeah i was comparing myself so
much and that's why i didn't want him
for like the longest time when we first
like protective because i was very
and then i think you were right to think
that because probably nine times out of
ten guys that are exactly like him
you would have been right but it seems
like he's he's different than those
yeah so far and so i was very very
insecure about that
initially but like after a while when i
decided to just chill and be like you
know what i'm gonna give him the benefit
of the doubt he's never
given me a reason to feel any type of
way
and so there's that i think the only
weird thing is and it's not even from
him but
when i first people first started to
figure out that he and i
were together people would then send me
screenshots and videos of him doing porn
with another girl
yeah as if like i didn't know i'm like
we're trying to like getting
yeah i knew this going into it like
you're not going to make me feel what
would they be
like what would the general tone be when
they would send those would it just be
like how dare you have sex with a porn
star or
no it's kind of like oh look at your
like you're so [ __ ] dumb
he's gonna like basically [ __ ] you and
leave and this and that
usually and like it's always guys and
it's always there
if you like scroll up in the like dm
request it's like i love you i love you
you're perfect
like you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] you're with
a porn star yeah you're gonna get dumped
after he [ __ ] you and
it's like that whole personality like
they really want to love a girl and then
they're just so pissed when they
you know you don't follow exactly what
they think you should do yeah and i
think it's also weird because
like my when i came into the podcast
world i had a long time boyfriend i was
with the same guy
from the time i was 14 to like 23 24. so
i was with him for like 9 10 years and
he was
like a nerdy filipino dude who liked
video games and anime
and so with a lot of the fan base from
where i work it's like bro we kind of
like 24 to 45 year old like
white dudes who kind of thought that
like oh like this nerdy like asian guy
got this
like attractive girl so clearly i can
[ __ ] her if she met me
and then the moment they saw like my
boyfriend who was the polar opposite
kind of like takes care of himself like
buff white dude
like blonde hair blue eyes are like oh
like suddenly now like i don't feel like
she would fake him yeah like she would
[ __ ] me anymore
because i knew she if she [ __ ] that
guy she'd [ __ ] me but now that she's
[ __ ] this guy
and he's a porn star so he has a huge
dick jumped out
yeah their beta jumped out wow like you
have a small dick and it shows
energy yeah they can never be that guy
yeah but it's like i'm not with him for
his dick
yeah for his heart it's just as big as
his dick
i love that i bet you get a lot of i get
these messages
uh as many places as i can at a girl
there we go
i get this message sometimes i don't
know what it is but there's like a
there's there's people out there who are
convinced that i only date white guys
really all of your all of your exes are
asian yeah yeah i don't know how that
became a thing but then
people comment like she well gina only
dates white guys i'm like
maybe like one time is it is it a common
thing like abg girls
date white guys no no i don't think so
no that's an
insecure thing i feel like a lot of
asian guys who are insecure about
being asian and dating like a hot girl
say [ __ ] like that almost like make
themselves feel better like oh well i
could never be a white guy so clearly
she doesn't like me it's like it's not
that
like that's your issue there's so many
like asian guys who are super attractive
that date outside of their race who date
in their race
i know short asian dudes who [ __ ]
kill it dating the
hottest girls you've ever seen just
because tim got
tim yeah
[Music]
but that's because like he has this like
confidence about him that's so
attractive it's everything else he
brings to the table
he's not like dwelling on the fact that
he's like a short asian dude he uses it
to his advantage
and so people want to be like oh it's
because you date only white guys like no
you're just insecure beta [ __ ] i bet
you get messages i
like me you get messages like oh you're
a white worshiper
or you're a sellout there's nothing
about you
at all that screams right worse exactly
not even one thing yeah weird
you're so [ __ ] asian cultured [ __ ]
gina yeah
like not even a thing about you as well
then i'll get comments people like gina
hates being asian she hates being
vietnamese i'm like really
when where where yeah it's so weird
like yeah i don't think you guys know me
very well no that's lack of information
yeah yeah because i get i get similar
every now and then yeah
i feel like ever since i started dating
my boyfriend like the
one white guy they're like oh absolutely
she only likes white guys now
like no i still really love you just
like asian men if i want
but like yeah this just happens to be my
boyfriend he happens to be white
it's not like i hate asian men now thing
it's
so weird what's sex with a former porn
star like um i was so intimidated at
first oh my god dude i would be here
what is that drove to [ __ ] costa he
used to live in orange county
uh and so i would drive to costa mesa
like trying to mentally prepare like if
we [ __ ] tonight i'm going to be in a
wheelchair like a white oh my god
oh my god did you watch his porn before
you had sex with him no but when i met
him
you've been doing research
but like when i met him and then he put
a photo of his dick
on the screen at work and so i saw it
and then like he had another dick pic
and they were passing the phone around i
saw her oh okay okay
okay and he has like a homer remember
guys she only likes it because she was
interested in him we don't just want
your dick it's
also one of those things we liked him
yeah he was like in a work setting
whereas like a comedy podcast this is
kind of what happens it's not like he
was just like hey look at my dick
yeah so it was fine but people never
worked it
yes absolutely and then i by the time i
like kind of
felt it because we were making out i was
like oh i don't know what to do
what if it doesn't fit like i didn't
know what to do
it's pretty it's very like to scale
normally it doesn't
so there's like there's a girl it's just
as long as it's thick it's like a
small it's like a police baton or like
the mag like
uh flashlights wow it's like a mag
flashlight so it's brutal is what you're
saying
yes it will i'm like take an eye out
duck shane
[Applause]
um where do you put down
the body is an amazing thing i'll say
that that's why the magician girl yeah
but um yeah the first time uh we
saw each other we started making out and
i got so intimidated i left immediately
after like i made out with him for five
minutes you know guys don't need you to
do anything to have sex right like why
would you be intimidated
no i was just like i was not mentally
prepared because i was like okay it's a
big dick whatever yeah
i was so [ __ ] scared of it because
like i kind of like brushed up on it i
was like huh that's my arm
and so i left immediately after the next
time i hung out with him i was like okay
i think i'm ready and i would like
while we're making i would whisper like
i want you to [ __ ] me
but i guess i said it so low he didn't
hear so after i left i was like oh
maybe he doesn't like me maybe he
doesn't want to [ __ ] me yeah and the
third time
out of the corner he's like what he's
like asmr
[ __ ] me please [ __ ] me i'm ready you're
ready because you couldn't say it
yeah yeah and then i
went really aggressive the third time we
hung out like [ __ ] me
oh okay yeah and then i told him like oh
i thought you didn't like me because you
didn't [ __ ] me the last time we hung out
he's like you said something
yeah absolutely but now it's like
i don't i don't know what was that first
time like the first time
was i gasped when you put it in
like i just had never felt something
that big in me before so
i feel like nikki knows what i'm talking
about because i hear that steve has a
baby baby she always gets um
according to nikki like even from high
school right you were saying
oops sorry i didn't know that you
somehow
nikki didn't objects could be small
honestly loki uh felt the same because
my first
boyfriend was the only guy i had sex
with for nine years and he had a pretty
big dick but i didn't know he had a big
dick
i just thought it was like a standard
kind of like he
had like a seven inch dick and everyone
thought were like making asian jokes
like oh he probably has a small dick and
so like she's not used to it whatever
the next guy i hung out with
after that like i was hooking up after
the breakup was
a white guy and he had a small not a
small dick but like a smaller dick yeah
and so like probably an average size
yeah and then like when i first
was like oh okay so like at least now i
know kind of to scale like what dicks
are like
you're like my boys are way bigger than
the white yeah why are people making
such a fuss about asian dances
they're all random even like they're all
they're all
random yeah they're all random and
people i thought it was kind of like
in my head i thought it was like a math
equation because people say like
asian girls have like tight small
[ __ ] so maybe that's why like as you
guys have small dicks like it's to fit
you know just like genetically maybe
that's what it was people don't believe
this do they
oh yeah they do some people do i feel
like some people really do think all
asian guys have tiny dicks and that's
not the case
wow because the first white dick i
[ __ ] was smaller and i was like oh
okay that's fine and then i went to my
boyfriend i was like i'm
in a wheelchair tomorrow okay
sometimes you gotta fake that gasp when
they first put it in you know you just
gotta fake it just make them feel better
oh i don't fake it see i faked it for a
while then i got to a point where i was
like i don't want to fake it anymore and
suddenly people got their feelings hurt
because i think i was like two
overzealous efforts and then like the
next time i was like i'm not gonna fake
an orgasm that i don't feel anymore just
like that's i'm not gonna do it
yeah for me for him like i'm just not
gonna do it and he went from like this
[ __ ] boy like maybe i'll text you later
like what's wrong you don't like me
why did you guess he's like did you come
i'm like if you had to ask i came over
here i came over yeah
[Applause]
my [ __ ] didn't get a cramp but i mean
it was funny it was the crosshairs
do you feel like it's too it's too big
to where you can't enjoy it though
because i've definitely had that where
like it hurts
and i'm like it doesn't feel it it's
it's nice when it either doesn't all the
way punch the [ __ ] out of it or it
somehow finds its way around it but some
of them are so big where it literally
will
like ram your cervix up inside of your
stomach yeah that should hurt so yeah
because i feel like people
underestimate having like a dick that
fits properly because if a dick fits
properly and they kind of like
hit the cervix a little bit like when
they like kind of like slam
into you they are also kind of like
tapping your [ __ ] which is nice
yeah and that's what i like whereas if
you have like extra dick hanging out
like you never get that little clip
right
right from there i want the clip yeah i
think somehow it's like a perfect amount
that works
yeah that's why in my head like if you
have too big of a dick do you just do
anal
because that's the only way like it'll
fit all the way oh if it's too big you
don't do anal what are you talking about
what you're putting a bigger baby in
your mouth like that
it fits more but then like the widening
i feel like i just gave myself away yeah
yeah
so how's your anus it's good it's fine
it's fine
it's fine apparently there's a rumor
that like asian girls don't like anal
is there that's what every single white
guy i have like hooked up with has told
me
they're like oh yeah asian girls would
be perfect but they don't do anal and
i'm like who
are you hooking up with right and also
like what there's so many weird like
races yeah there's like
racist [ __ ] about like asian girls it's
weird it's like
somebody asked me why uh [ __ ] was like
sideways because they're like yeah
they're like oh asian [ __ ] are just
like different i was like
different i heard that and um there was
a it was a movie it was like hannibal
lecter like the prequel or some [ __ ]
and someone mentioned that about an
asian woman
on screen about how her [ __ ] sideways
and i remember seeing this when i was in
like i was like 14-ish 15 i think
and i remember thinking i'm like wait
that's true i didn't know that
no way for real many
no but yeah but like i i didn't know
that obviously that was a lie until
where that came later on i know like
what did you
think happened i spread my legs and it
smiles at you like i don't like
what right it's just like hello i don't
get it i cursed
image in my brain now that is absolutely
a curse
there are so many uneducated people i
saw a tick tock recently where this guy
swore that women can't fake orgasms
because when they clench like that that
means they came
oh
yeah you know we're doing it right now
you clinch in and then also you push out
yeah
so according to him you're having an
orgasm right now yeah right now
don't be fooled gentlemen yeah
academy award winning [ __ ] right here
absolutely
oscar-worthy performance actually no i
don't i don't give any more performances
that was my younger pick me girl i got
to make sure you feel
happy about yourself it teaches girls
that it's okay to just like go and fake
orgasms to make someone else feel better
i think it's the movie
like the the [ __ ] the the culture
yeah like culture not just in hollywood
but like
even within conversations it's always
like
oh like like he gave me such a great
orgasm whatever you know how like in
high school you try to be
all cool like you know all about sex and
[ __ ] and then people make up [ __ ]
because then they watch porn and
yeah it's like and then it sets the
standard that you're like oh i guess i
have to meet this standard
i don't know it's really interesting
there's a [ __ ] like a man pleasing
kind of thing
just like you know i have to make him
feel good or else he's gonna it was it's
learned from all that medium [ __ ]
yeah don't fake your orgasms yeah unless
you want to wrap it up and just get them
out
and speaking of wrapping up we need to
get you out no i'm just kidding
hi guys no thank you so much kat for
joining us for having
a lot of fun definitely have to come
back yeah absolutely yeah
absolutely we're going to research your
stuff and your boyfriend stuff
respectfully respectfully
i'm not going to do that because i want
to be your friend so yeah i don't know
i just want to look at your feet no well
yeah so tell the people where they can
find you
um you can find me on instagram my
handle is
t3i's three e's and n tn
um and then i have a youtube channel
if you just type in my name it'll pop up
i don't really post on there i need to
do
more uh and that's about it yeah find me
on only fans with the
same uh instagram it's the same as my
instagram handle
so if you want to see feet or you want
to see me in like a
wet t-shirt by all means we'll link it
all in the description box yeah thank
you so much for having me this is so
much fun i'm so used to being with a
bunch of guys
and it's really refreshing being with a
bunch of girls yeah it's so [ __ ] nice
this is like
a rarity i'm super glad you're this one
well guys make sure
to subscribe if you haven't make sure to
give us five stars if you're listening
and like this video as well and comment
down below
what did you think about this video
we'll see you next time peace
bye